Today I'm being set on fire three two
So in the first stuntmen react video Eric just briefly mentioned as a side thought. Hey we should light you on fire
You should light him on fire sometime. Oh, yeah, I'm down two weeks later when the video came out. He sent me a text
So when are we letting go on fire? My honest first thought was absolutely let's go. Let's do it. That sounds like the best
I'm so down. I thought about it. You know, I have a mom
I have a dad and you know before I typed never I actually thought it would be really cool to show you guys how
Stuntman pull off one of the most daring and dangerous stunts in Hollywood movies using my body as tribute to this whole thing
So yeah, we have Eric here today. He let me on fire with this crew and it's a great
I have no idea what to expect other than the fact that I will be lit on fire at some point today
Yo, is it true that I have to like eat ice cubes before I get set on fire yeah you have to yeah ok
Ok
Hey Eric. Yeah, absolutely for real
Dude, I was about to eat so much ice. What's up guys? I am with Eric Linden and Omid Zader
These are Hollywood professional stunt man stunt coordinators. So this is your your team. We're gonna we're here to keep you safe
There's a lot of different videos out there that talk about this process
But I think what's really cool is we're gonna step a guy who hasn't done it through this process and keep him safe
There are a lot of things involved to keep someone safe, especially sending someone on fire that's never been on fire
I love that seeing people's first
Reactions and just the property the fire and they learn the basics of fire how fire always moves up
You want to keep it behind you away from your face? One of the safest ways is what we're gonna be doing today
We're all professionals
We've been brought up through the ranks and have learned trial through fire
That we just want to educate you guys on what happens don't do this. It's a really bad idea people's first question
Always is what does it feel like well generally like nothing you're just freezing as eric has mentioned in previous videos
It's the rest of the adrenaline the gel it shouldn't feel like anything because as soon as you feel any kind of heat
Well, you're kind of in trouble but it's fun if it's done correctly with the right team you guys the right thing. Yes, sir
Yeah. All right. So yeah, you guys so ideally what we want to do. We want to light your arm on fire
Okay, then we like to let your legs on fire. Perfect
Okay, and then we like to light both arms both legs and you're back on fire
When you're setting somebody on fire you got a protector through the fire
Gel, but you can't just put fire gel on, you know, then you're putting fuel on to the fire. Gel
Which is what actually catches on fire. Yeah, it's a it's not the fire gel itself
The fire gel is just strictly like a barrier to protect you against the fire
Now some of the things that we're gonna help the fire gel out with are these different layers of fire protective clothing?
There's many different kinds there's there's no mechs. There's fire resistant cotton
There's something called carbon acts all of it kind of has its own specific uses
Ultimately, what we're gonna do for this one is we're gonna use this cotton layer two shirts for you. Yeah, okay
This layer is called pbi. This is actually fireproof. Well, it does not light on fire. Well
Normal, that's the weird part. That's crazy
Everybody's gonna say well what if you put it in lava?
Does this burn at some point? Yes it will but by that point your eyeballs melt out of your head, okay?
Sweet so we don't have to worry about that. We'll never get to those type of temperatures
We are gonna be lighting you on fire with the coldest possible fire that makes it that makes sense to me
Keep it as safe as possible, right?
Now
The other component to this is going to be fire. Gel. There's many different kinds of fire. Gel
We have action factories don't gel today. This is some of the best stuff in the business
So that's what we're gonna use cool if you say it's all
Essentially organic. Can I eat this? Yeah, wait, really?
Eddie like it's kind of fresh actually
Fresh nice. It's like a honey honey mint. I like that. That's nice
So what we'll do is we're gonna take this and completely cover the clothes with it right on our left arm. Which one right?
Ways left arm just in case
You're probably gonna get cold it kind of draws the heat out of your body
Okay, and then eventually we'll put it all over your head and all over everything to keep you safe
Okay, and then we will put that wardrobe over top of you. So you have three layers of clothing
They are all covered in fire. Gel then another layer of clothing that will be burned. I'm excited to be honest. Thank you
Is it it's a nervous excitement, you know, as you can see, this is a time-consuming process
Typically when we're doing this on set we need about a 45 minute heads up once our guy is completely ready in an ideal situation
We walk him straight to set and light him on fire
Like there's not a lot of downtime
What will happen is if you wait too long?
The gel I have up here will start sliding down his arm and we'll pull up
Down here and I'll also do that in his legs
He'll still have some gel but like the ideal system all over his body
Starts to break down over time so you don't want him sitting there for three hours waiting to be settling on five
I'm feeling like an extra like 10 12 pounds. Wait until your little body's going
I know just like 40 pounds heavier. Feel like a ketchup packet
Pull this out like that. Okay. So is it go ahead and pass up test the guys bourbon?
Yeah, we're good just for the size of this burn more than likely it'll either a burn out or B
We'll just throw a little wet rag on it cuz this is very small if anything happens to go wrong
Just let me in the team handle it everybody just kind of step back. We will take care of it
Make sure clean feels good. Do I need to stop drop and roll at any point you do? No, okay
We will get you okay cool sauce, and so we're gonna put a little bit of fuel
This is what burns awesome all a little bit for now
Mel's like hot glue. He said I think so
I'm on fire. Good day
I feel feel pretty good. Just looking at some fire my right now so warm at all not yet
So let me know if start still long. Okay, so could I cook us more over this you think it'd be positive?
Nice dude, is it getting warm at all? Yeah a little bit a little bit. So that's just dissipated
It's gonna warm up its fire is the thing that we want to avoid
Especially when we're doing a bigger burn with you. Is it getting hot?
You need to let us know when you are getting warm
So we can put you out even once the fire is out if it remains hot
The very heat of it could give you a burn on your skin, even though the fire is completely gone. I'd literally be cooked
Yes, my bean you cooked a lot. Have you cooked?
Okay, cool, man, so I don't want to like completely engulf you in flames yet
Once it starts to get around your face and everything
It gets to be a completely different deal if you're comfortable with it. What I'd like to do is completely prep your whole body
Okay and light your legs on fire?
Okay, let's let my legs on fire cuz I don't know if I'm ready for the full body yet like on it
honestly, I'm like, I'm cool with that, but my whole body like both my arms my legs and my back do
Look and if that's something that you're not ready for no pressure
Ready yeah, let's do it. I get down to the tones you get all the girls
Yeah tuition like a big for firstborn
You gotta take a big scoop of this and put it on your your crotch
Because I'm not doing it but you guys I oh
my oh
Yeah, just put it inside
Doesn't so I don't want you serious, you're no 104 series I
Think of a third time gotta get two of you and windows God dang it
Why just that part by the way, that was completely unnecessary. It was just a message
This is smelled nice and fresh
This is what I'll be for Halloween, dude
man
I've been to the airport dude. I've been the TSA before has it been my for TSA agents at the same time. No
That would be a first
Yeah, dude
Yes
Ie breath you got in through the nose out the nose
I really do feel like a salamander snapping pics then great. All right
Okay, let's
Chances are if you're watching this video you like moviemaking and chances are to watch a channel
You're probably into visual effects
Now when you're doing visual effects usually need two elements to add your footage
Explosions blood splatters sparks that kind of stuff the thing is when you have to go and buy a pack of like 20 blood hits
Just to use the couple. It's kind of expensive
So we've teamed up with action V effects to curate what we call the battle box
It's a collection of all the elements you need to do a cool action scene at an affordable price
We've taken the best from each pack couple explosions a couple blood splatters a couple muzzle flashes and sparks
All the good stuff and action the effects man. They just knock it out of the park with their elements
They're such high quality elements. Its corridor digital calm slash battle boxes. I'll link in the description below
I think you'll enjoy it if you're trying to get individual effects yourself. Let's go Mike Clint on fire
Every stop talking now overall focused
He's just quiet work just like incense clint's concentration. He's breathing through his nose. So harder now
He's trying not to sugar and be cold. I
Wonder if he's regretting it now, but either way it's too I turn back. It's only one way to warm them up
we've layered him up with all the layers Reid gelled as we put each layer on make sure it's nice and thick and
This rubber suit is like not necessary for this one, but we're doing anyway
Just kind of help show the process
The suit essentially keeps the gel in I feel like a garbage man already like a space garbage, man
That's Steve, it's Steve did you do you know we're doing right now just you did like pick up some guns
Okay, put these out so that place to park. I'm a considerate landlord. I am NOT
Just any landlord Who am I I am
Lord clearly in about ten minutes Clint is going to do his first full body burn
Where is he going to do this by the way? Wait a minute
Dude, seriously? Oh
You're covering that we'll make sure the scorch marks are cleared away and I did it about 30 years ago
And I had to put this gel on me and I did on fire while on fire jumping jacks
And it looked great god, this is great
You know when you're like trying to run but you can't yeah a fight but you can't that's how I feel right now dude I
Feel like
Frickin Chum though. What we're gonna do is we're gonna fuel both of your legs
Yeah, and then we're going to go ahead and light that on fire. Okay, as you start to feel like it's warm
I want you to go ahead and call it
Oh, there's not a whole lot of wind in here. But once we get out there, it's gonna be a little bit different
Okay, cool. Okay, everybody set
Do it
Kind of move around a little bit. I always liked you
Yeah, yes Joe, yes people show go ahead and stand back up
Like it feels nice
I that can feel some warmth the slightest warmth in my legs and that's very nice for now because I am
Pretty cold what I'd like to do next in the next stage of all this is we'll prep your head. Yeah
This is awesome. There's a moment. Yeah, I'm not gonna forget this forget Eric brother. Gel all over my chin, dude
I can't hear I'd like to light up another
One arm okay, but we'll do it much bigger
Yeah, and I would like you to kind of move around and feel the fire a little bit. Okay you good with that?
Yeah, I'm good with that
Don't move around love it
Well, yeah see the wind feelin it
Hotspots good anything good good. Okay good, right
Now the real question is do you want to do a big?
Like more fire or an or five. Do you want to do all of them? I
Mean we're I didn't get suited up for nothing, dude
Yeah, so we're doing yeah, we're doing it. Yeah, we're good
I'm gonna touch up your face make sure that this is completely coverage everywhere and then we're gonna we're gonna go for it
So what we'll do is I'll fuel you up nice and big
Let's just dudes once it's just one time. Yeah. Yeah. I want you to hold your breath the entire time, okay
And you will run a jog speed right down to there and then when you get to the blanket
Me down and out like a superhero. Yes. It just landed. Yes, like all cool. Okay. Yeah
Yeah, I can do that and we'll put you out. This is the moment of truth
We've brought to you and prepared you. I'm ready man to say I'm ready
Ready, three two
Does anything hurt are they good good. I've gotta stand up
Maybe just like right here great
I have no I got feel good right now. Oh wow
Grab fire man. That's the whole bag. That's everything
What a fire inspectors dream the real question here is
We're asking need another one
One do one more some sort of variation I will light you up and say action and you kind of do a turn a
Little bit of the chicken dance and then go at any point
Even if you only make it three steps if you want out go down. Okay. All right. Let's go ahead three
two one
Hotspots, goodgoodgood
Water bottles great
Thanks to you. Oh, really? Good. Thank you. Good job, boys. How's your nose?
You've been a safe keeping a real man those it's great. Everything's good. Yeah
Killed it man, all these people came out to see you burn. I guess that's how it is, huh?
This spin is great
Man, well, I think I feel like Clint's got a profile Cougars are one. Yeah, there it is, dude
Thank you so much for dude
Okay
Have an amazing experiences. Yeah
Freakin sweet dude. It was exhilarating. Yeah
I felt like I loved being in the zone and I love it when it comes down to like super focused
I love those moments and that was definitely one of those moments for me
I felt like I could a jog like three to four times that distance, but who knows?
Maybe there's like a spike like right after I did double that distance
There's just like I am I'm on fire and I'm actually burning I had I don't know
I don't want to push the limits, you know, but I felt good like I don't feel like I'm on fire
I don't feel like I'm burning right now. I feel great work of art
That's what I call it a work of art and it went in you got two good takes and Clint is doing great
And he's wonderful. He has no PTSD that I can see
He's a happy guy. Yeah. Yeah. It's a very unique art form
It's just really cool to see you demonstrate it for us here
This was not to show you guys how to do this or how to light yourselves on fire. That's absolutely not what we wanted
We wanted to show you how to keep somebody safe
And just what how much work goes into it and how much knowledge
You need to have to be able to light somebody on fire and get them out of it safely
completely unscathed
Yeah, so thank you so much for having us and please do not try this at home by this point
you guys got me nowit, but you can follow Erik when didn't have
His website, but seriously a big thank you to you in the whole team for coming out here and helping us with this
Because I just hope that we continue to like deepen people's respect and understanding to the craft. Absolutely
Successful stunts. Nobody got hurt
It's Miller time
So if you want to light yourself on fire, but you don't have a Hollywood stunt team chances
Are you going to need visual effects?
We're gonna get that fire from you ask through your computer to me and I hear you there you get the battle box
it's a collection of all of our favorite elements through action the effects everything we use from explosions to muzzle flashes to bullet hits all
Brought into one affordable package for you
We can click the link in description below and you can see each and every element
So if you're a visual effects artist just signing out. I already got a great library. I think you're gonna find this very useful
I almost forgot if you buy anything else and action the effects you can use a promo code corridor for 10% off
Please consider subscribing guys. Thank you for watching the video. I think Clint had the time of his life. See you the next one